Justice.
That is a good one.
Let's circle back to young people,
um,
because the future is going to belong to them before we know it,
Huh?
Uh,
remarkable and a very insightful and engaging human being.
Jonathan Height is perhaps a,
a leading example of somebody who's seen from a left perspective himself.
How dangerous all of his ears on how we're endangering young people by not being
honest with them,
not encouraging them to,
to explore what they instinctively feel needs to be explored going back to our
earlier topic and when leaving them without the resilience that they're going to
need to confirm if you like a free and prosperous society.
And A,
I had a question he would run relating to this,
which I'd just like to read,
uh,
in his piece of the coddling of the American mind.
Jonathan Heit outlines why millennials today are so fragile and lacking
resilience in life and in relationships,
in university courses in the workplace,
and what has led to this overwhelming push to be protected from anything
difficult or uncomfortable or offensive.
And he calls it the flight to safety.
And I think you've used that expression.
Um,
he outlines the core reason for this fragility of mind and emotion.
He says it stems firstly from overfunctioning and over protective parents.
Then schools now reaches into our universities and of course more people than
ever.
I go to universities in the west,
so they formed a much bigger bulk in our community afterwards and at least some
tragically unprepared and unarmed for life and relationships.
Would you comment on,
I think it's good to take a step back from that and think about it in the
broadest possible terms.
There is definitely an epidemic of over protective parenting,
but it's useful to ask why.
And my suspicions are,
is that this is driven by very fundamental biological and cultural phenomena
that aren't generally considered in relationship to this issue.
We don't have very many children.
We don't have
12 you know,
six of whom died.
We have one or two
that makes them very precious,
right?
We're unwilling to take risks with them and no wonder.
And then we also have the much later in life.
And so like if you have a kid when you're 18 you're still a kid.
You know you're going to go out and have your life,
right?
Because you're so while you were in the,
in the height of your exploratory,
you're,
you're in the height of the exploratory part of your life.
You're not going to overprotect your kid because you're still a kid.
But if you're 40 and have one child,
it's like all your eggs are in one basket.
And the probability that you're going to take undue risks with that precious
person is very,
very low.
Now obviously there's some advantages to that because great,
you would devote resources to your child,
you know,
and foster their development.
But the downside is that you have every motivation to hover and maybe you're
also extraordinarily desperate as a mother to maintain that bond with your child
because you've struggled so long to achieve it.
It's a highly,
highly valuable,
you can't take a risk.
Well,
so these,
so we might say,
well,
perhaps over protective parenting is a secondary unintended consequence of the
birth control pill.
And the fact that people now have children later in life could easily be,
you know,
if you have six kids,
it's like,
what are you going to do?
Hype helicopter,
parent them.
It's like,
no,
you're so tired.
You can't even get off the couch.
If you have six kids and they're,
they outnumber you,
right?
They're raising each other.
They're competing and they're taking each other down a peg.
They're not,
there's no overprotection there,
but with the,
with a single child landscape or dual child landscape,
mostly a single child landscape,
then you're going to overprotect and then that ethos starts to permeate the
schools and it starts to permeate the higher education institutions as those
children mature,
and then that all reinforces it.
Not Good.
It's not obvious what to do about it either because if it is driven by
demographics in that,
in that sense,
it's a much more intractable problem that we think.
So I did some of that in 12 rules for life,
you know,
I said,
look,
what you have to understand is that you're a danger to your children no matter
what.
Right?
You can let them go out in the world and be hurt or you can overprotect them and
hurt them that way.
So you,
here's your choice.
You can make your children competent and courageous or you can make them safe,
but you can't make them safe because life isn't safe.
So if you sacrifice their courage and competence on the altar of safety,
then you disarm them completely and all they can do is pray to be protected.
So in the very act of trying to do the right thing by them,
although often with a selfish motive right off of the surface mining,
we
strip why the tools and the equipment and the understanding they really need to
make life work.
Well,
that's the,
that's the DePaul mother,
right?
That was for great discovery of the dark mother and the dark mother is the
person.
She's the witch in Hansel and Gretel gingerbread house.
Lost children too good to be true.
It's like a house of candy.
Wow.
Who could want anything better?
What lives inside the House of Candy,
the which that wants to fatten you up and eat you.
Right.
A cautionary tale about over protective parents,
over protective mothers,
about the over protective feminine.
It's like the psychoanalysts,
they were so said,
the good mother necessarily fails at such a brilliant phrase.
It's like you can't,
as you,
as your child matures,
you have to fail more and more as a mother.
Right.
Until by the time you're 30 you're your child's 30 let's say 25 for that matter,
you're not their mother anymore.
I mean obviously you are,
but the relationship has hit something like quasi peer status,
not entirely obviously,
but the child is independent,
able to stand up on their own two feet and take on the world.
Okay,
now we say this thing or the university student runs into some difficulties with
study or whatever and it brings the parents in to talk to the faculty.
Yeah.
Or they go off in color.
I mean when I went to Queens University a week ago and there was a lot of noise
and and horror around that,
you know that the people who were decrying my visit set up coloring book
stations so that people could be comforted because you know the evil professor
was coming to talk.
It's like,
and you know as a clinician and height knows this as well and all the clinicians
worth their salt.
No,
this the worst thing you can do for someone who's anxious is overprotect them.
It makes them worse.
The clinical literature on that is crystal clear.
What you do for people who are hyper anxious is gradually expose them with their
voluntary consent to increasingly threatening situations that cures them.
It's exactly the opposite of what all the mental health professionals so,
and I use that term extraordinarily lightly or trying to do to produce safe
spaces on the university campus.
Like if a safe as if it's space needs to be defined as safe.
You can be sure that's the one thing.
It is not
drove and this has been fascinating.
Let me pay you a compliment.
In some ways,
I think the most valuable thing you can do for us is to model the courage to
speak your mind.
You do it forcefully,
you do it courageously,
you do it compassionately because the reality is you only have to spend a bit of
time with you to realize that you actually care,
especially about our young people and what they're experiencing.
And especially for our young men because we know boys model themselves are men
who they respect
you.
They are great job of modeling courage in the face of it.
Well,
there's something I like to say maybe in closing about courage.
People say that to me and you know,
I don't think it's exactly right.
There's a,
there's a line in the Old Testament,
the fear of God is the beginning of wisdom and I think it's more like that.
It's not that I'm courageous,
it's that I'm afraid of the right things.
So when I made my videos,
it wasn't like that didn't make me nervous,
but I was less nervous about going back to bed and not saying what I had to say,
that I was about making the videos because I know where this is going.
I don't want to go there.
And so it's,
it's not so much courage.
It's that it's a matter of,
uh,
it's,
it's less risky to say something than to remain silent when,
you know,
there's something to be said.
I know that to be the case.
And so lots of times in life it's like there's no pathway forward that's going
to shield you from risk.
You get to pick this risk or you get to pick this risk.
And I think I picked the lesser risk and that might be wise,
but I'm not so sure it's courageous.
Well,
I think it's admirable.
Let's leave it on that basis.
All right.
Thank you.
Thank you very much for the conversation.